hello freak [ __ ] can I ask a USC
question yes please do what's the what's
the Hollywood babble-on but over what
happened with Nunez well she got
something called sinusitis
she has apparently like severe sinus
infections that affect her balance and
they get really bad and she got one the
day of the weigh-ins she made it through
the weigh-ins and then she was having
like a serious episode to the point
where they checked her into the hospital
and the word was that she wanted to
compete but her coaches did not want her
to compete they look look you're having
like a really hard time like walking
like apparently when your sinuses get
like really inflamed it [ __ ] with your
equilibrium in air yeah this is second
and third-hand by the way right I didn't
talk to her right and you know that's
what you'd have to do you'd have to have
her talk about it but it's super
unfortunate because that was in well in
my opinion was the highest level women's
MMA bout ever in terms of the overall
ability of the two athletes I think
valentina Shevchenko and Amanda Nunez
they represent the peak yep these are
the this is the best we've ever seen
yeah Nunez is a ruthless knockout
striker she beat the [ __ ] out of Ronda
Rousey and she choked the [ __ ] out of me
should take she's a real legit black
belt in Brazilian jiu-jitsu knockout
striker and then Valentina Shevchenko is
a Muay Thai champion ridiculous stand up
and you know she caught Giuliana pinion
with an arm bar from the guard like her
ground game is nasty too right I mean
Pena is legit for her to catch Pena with
an arm bars that's staggering and her
striking is so good like you saw in the
Holly Holm fight she shot Holly Holm
down whereas like I mean Holly Holm [ __ ]
Tubbs remained around to me with a
question mark kick dropped her with a
straight left hand she never had close
to that kind of success against
Valentina right Valentina's super high
level with her striking her movement she
fights southpaw and she is that
beautiful check right hook that she
throws it like keeps everybody minding
their P's and Q's she's in a super
well-rounded game so it's really
unfortunate that those two didn't go at
it but it's going to be a good fight I
think they're going to schedule it again
for the event that
after the end of July event I think it's
2:15 they're going to schedule it for
but then me like Dana White said now
Amanda Nunez would never headline an
event again and I just don't think you
can force someone to fight if she really
did have a seat
you
the company word but if she's like was
that [ __ ] up I just can't imagine she
wasn't that [ __ ] up I mean it's got to
suck
have you spent millions of dollars
promoting a fight and then here it is
yeah and then if people bought the
pay-per-view and then it falls apart you
got to give refunds and I don't know
welcome to welcome to the music industry
when it was that it's you know it's big
peak in the 90s and people would like
write big checks for stuff and like I
yeah this is gonna be gonna get Mariah
Carey for millions of dollars here's her
thing and then she goes well she has a
meltdown she went crazy oh here's yeah
and like they're like what did we just
spend our money on what happened just
now
mmm I don't mind carrying crazy what
happened I think she had a meltdown one
of those maybe she's got a bad dick
wanna to catch a bad dick block I i I've
never personally I've never caught a bad
dick so if you got a good dick
I have not that I'm aware of karma dick
dick kitchen ambivalent dick I have not
caught an ambivalent dick yeah I keep
going I mean I might there might be one
in there somewhere I wonder I wonder I
mean it's got it's got to be away
ya know but you know somebody wrote a
big check you have an artist who had a
meltdown didn't deliver because it's
you're talking about where we are
merchants of emotion that's when we do
right and sometimes they can overwhelm
that as a no but that is a you know
volatile thing and it's stories all the
time and you know with fighters one
little dumb thing walking up the stairs
to the Octagon he can pull you know your
ACL [ __ ] separates from your body
yeah you can slip you Kevin Randleman
was backstage preparing for a fight once
and he stepped on a pipe and slipped and
fell on his head and was concussed yeah
like right before the main event right
before the main event he was walking
backstage he stepped on something
slipped his leg when I bone he hit his
[ __ ] head and he was concussed and
they canceled the fight yeah that was
like like a mess I want to say that was
in 1997 or 1998 or somewhere around
there and it was like what yeah that can
happen for sure and then for a fighter
there's so much about who they are is
dependent upon their confidence
their state of mind and if she hears
that the UFC is pissed at her she had to
pull out of the fight and then they say
that they'll never have her headline an
event again and she goes from being this
superstar with to spectacular
performances against the most popular
women's fighters of all time those two
between Miesha Tate and Ronda Rousey I
would say arguably the most popular
women fighters of all time
coincidentally they're both the hottest
how weird mmm you know like you got if
you're going to be a chicken you got to
be a fighter it helps a lot of your odd
doesn't I I'm that hot and I'm not a
chick I know it's both of those things I
didn't want to bring it up though they
want to rub your face right but yeah I
mean who knows how she's going to bounce
back from that sucks it sucks with
Valentina too
[Applause]
[Music]